when you were offered the Mandalorian
did you have any say on the episodes
that you got to direct or was it sort of
like would you like to direct the
Mandalorian and here's what you will do
if you say yes I had gone down to visit
Favreau on the set of season one
Mandalorian uh because everyone was
talking about the volume technology I
love Star Wars and I love favro
um so when season two came about you
know John called and said would you like
to come down an episode I was like yeah
absolutely
um it was the second episode of season
two that I originally signed on for
um and John had written sort of a rough
script and then I fleshed the script out
and we worked on it together uh and then
uh that was the first one we shot for
season two it wasn't the first episode
aired but it was the second episode here
it was the first one we shot and um they
were psyched about it and they had this
finale coming up uh which all he said
was we're gonna take a there's gonna be
sort of a big swing in in the finale I
was like what they got going on and uh
he said it's going to be a very
emotional episode and he sort of talked
me through it was about and I read the
script I was like absolutely I'm doing
this we already started I think you know
working on the script and formulating
quantumania uh but it was still early on
and we had Thomas like I I cannot pass
up this chance because obviously you got
to work with the volume technology how
much was it when you were on set
directing the Mandalorian we were like
oh I'm using this on quantumania well it
was a technology I wanted to know about
right and I wanted to see you know how
it worked and and sort of how it could
be applied so I didn't necessarily
specifically think but it was definitely
in the back of my mind you know we're
going to do quantumania and we have to
render the quantum realm vividly there
were things that I wanted to do but I
wasn't sure that uh the volume
technology was ready for it what it was
great about on Mandalorian is you know
shooting these great location backdrops
and then putting out there and it feels
very photo real but we were going to be
creating digital backdrops some based on
on unreal photography but it was a
different thing altogether and we also
wanted a lot of movement within those
screens so we ended up you know using
the volume technology it was it was
great for certain environments but not
necessarily right for other ones there's
also um just uh size and shape uh things
that that sometimes our sets are too big
for the volume so we would use partial
sets so it was definitely one of the
tools we used in our toolkit and the
actors love it right because they get to
see a version of what they're going to
see in the movie and uh you know the
interactive lighting is obviously great
but it's great the actors love it uh but
you know it's it's not always the right
tool but I liked it because we wanted to
create all these different parts of the
quantum realm that had to look and feel
differently so it was cool to have some
that were and some that weren't do you
envision using the volume technology in
like most of your future things is it
something that's like not I hate the
term Game Changer but is it a game
changer for your future I think again
it's like the idea of LED technology and
using that as interactive light and
visual effects is good you know there
are limitations to it and we we push
that system to its limit on this movie
uh and there are things that it could do
and it can't do but also what works so
well in Mandalorian is they have a lot
of lead time because they're doing a
whole series to sort of invest and
create these environments uh and on the
schedule we were on it's uh it's not
always right for that situation but it's
cool I like the volume one of the things
about this movie is I think you have I'm
going to use five or ten VFX shots in
the film I'm gonna say that's maybe
that's a low number
um were you ever nervous because the VFX
industry is going through some
difficulty trying to make release dates
so were you ever nervous about will we
get this done in time I think that's
always the case on every movie even if
you have a small amount of visual
effects but obviously I think we have
you know over 2600 visual effects shots
and and
uh they're really about convincing the
audience that you're in this you know in
in this Quantum realm right they're
vital to the storytelling
um I really value the visual effects
artists and and the companies that we
use and work on with these movies so we
were very good I think about you know I
got a lot of previz and post viz done
very very early uh as we were shooting
and then in my director's cut to try and
give everybody as much of a landing pad
as possible
um there are so many movies being made
now and and streaming shows that require
visual effects
um and you need to give those artists
time to to not only design the shots but
to to render them as well
um we were very prepared in terms of the
designing shots we had post viz in there
from from third floor who we always work
with that was really really you know
specific uh so we were able to give
those to the vendors and they they had a
really good jumping off book you have
done basically except for Mandalorian
you've been working on Ant-Man I think
since like 2013 or 25 14. 2014 yeah yeah
do you envision
um another Ant-Man movie in your future
or are you sort of like you've seen the
other Marvel movies that have been
announced and you're like I kind of want
to play in one of those like sandboxes
it's interesting because you know
I'm I'm superstitious about this stuff
right I mean when we were doing the
first Ant-Man there was certainly no
guarantee we were going to get to make a
second one and even after the second one
there was no guarantee when we finally
you know announced that oh okay we're
gonna make Quantum Mania we're gonna get
to do this I just it was it was all
marshaling all the forces onto that
because we knew
if we're gonna get to do a third one
it's got to be something altogether
different we got to show the audience
something different and for me it was
the quantum realm of being able to
create that whole world worlds within
worlds and answer those questions what
the hell was Janet Van Dyke doing down
there for 30 years and also to kick off
phase five to like to introduce Kang the
Cocker uh with Jonathan so I was focused
on on that thing now that the trilogy is
done uh who knows I mean I you know
again years ago you and I've talked
about this before I developed Fantastic
Four like 20 years ago I channeled I
channeled a lot of my Fantastic Four
love into the Ant-Man world and
specifically into quantumania you know
it's it's no mistake that both are kind
of dysfunctional families of superheroes
and in Fantastic Four they may go into
the Negative Zone we went into the
quantum realm I I really scratched that
itch with these movies so um are you
interested in doing one of the other
upcoming Marvel things or do you want to
play in Another sandbox I want to play
in a lot of different sandboxes I would
never say no to you know a future doing
stuff at Marvel I mean I I've loved my
time at Marvel I love the people in
Marvel uh and I love what they've been
able to do I mean you know it's it's
strange because 2014 is not that long
ago but you know
the idea of this interconnected Universe
of movies is a relatively new idea I
mean at that time it was you know right
after Iron Man was like oh this is weird
and kind of revolutionary people forget
that you know now they just take it for
granted
um and I think with Ant-Man because he
played in the margins of the MCU for so
long right he wasn't a proper Avenger
for for a long time
um that gave me sort of freedom to not
have to like we really didn't deal with
Infinity Stones in those movies uh and
then with this we were given a free
reign no other Marvel movie was doing
Quantum realm so we got to like that was
our playing field that we could
introduce some characters from the comic
books gentura and then you know other
ones quas vebs on them that we just
created out of whole cloth so that was
we had a bunch of freedom but yeah I
would I would I would definitely come
back to Marvel yeah I'm just thinking
because I know you love the comics and I
know you know the X-Men and other
characters are being introduced in the
not so distant future and I'm just
thinking about you as a fan being able
to you know play yeah I think so I mean
it would have to be the right thing I'm
not an X-Men guy Jeff loveness he's an
X-Men guy uh I love the X-Men I love
watching X-Men movies I don't want to
make an X-Men movie uh and that's what's
great about Marvels because there's this
infinite to me the ones that are are
interesting to me now are kind of the
Lesser I mean Ant-Man at the time we
knew Ant-Man who's a founding member of
The Avengers but in terms of the public
Consciousness you know he was probably a
B level maybe a c-level character who
knows it depends on your point of view I
love that about him I love
I've always been sort of like to me he
was almost like a subculture Marvel hero
it's What drew me to bring it on like a
movie about cheerleaders that's weird uh
and Drew me to Down With Love it's like
a a sort of Rock Hudson Doris Day homage
as a as a romantic comedy sentence I'm
into that I had the same attraction to
to Ant-Man it was the same kind of thing
so I like the idea I would do I would do
a Nova movie I love a man called Nova
that seems cool I love Jonathan Majors
as Kang and I love his delivery in the
movie very calm and it's perfect so can
you talk about how did he come up with
that delivery was it a team how did how
did that get figured out Jonathan and I
spent a lot of time together uh over
zoom and finally in person long before
we shot a frame in the movie
um and we talked about like what it
would be like to be in the presence of
counting the Conqueror who doesn't live
in a straight line and experiences time
in an entirely different way and in fact
has almost infinite experiences you know
he he says to Scott you're an Avenger
have I killed you before it's like wait
holy you've battled The Avengers
before or were they variants of Avengers
and like you've you've done it so many
times you can't quite remember that's
scary that's that's that's a whole new
flavor for an antagonist in one of these
movies
and we also talked about like
what would it be like to converse with
that guy and the idea that he
experiences time in a way that there's
not one bit of wasted energy
he moves in a very deliberate way
and when he speaks
you know it's it's there's an economy of
words if he says something he means it
and we love the idea of putting that
energy up against Paul Rudd who whether
he's you know joking around or he's
nervous he's going to try and joke his
way out of a situation and Kang is not
having that but Jonathan and I spent a
lot of time and we talked about
Alexander the Great and we talked about
Napoleon and we talked about like real
world conquerors and then we also talked
about like
you know trauma
and you know as human beings who live in
a straight line human beings experience
trauma well what if this guy has
experienced multiple almost unending
trauma we like the idea of Kang being
kind of a broken man right a man out of
time but also
this guy's seen some right he's
like he's been through a lot
um and also we talked about connection
and in a movie the Ant-Man movies have
always been about family
Scott and hope Hank and Jen and Cassie
they all have each other right they're
this unit and Kang is is a man alone and
what does connection and attachment mean
to a being like that and we love the
idea as we explore this backstory about
uh Janet and Kang's time together in the
quantum realm that maybe this
relationship with Janet whatever it is
two people who are stranded and working
for a common goal of getting out maybe
that's the closest connection he's ever
had to another being
and when she finds out his true nature
she feels betrayed by this is not who
you said you were but he also feels
betrayed because he said I'll get you
out of here I made a promise and she's
not going to accept that bargain so
there's this Mutual betrayal I and we
love that idea that felt like a really
here we have a powerful villain
um like all great villains we hope like
we kind of understand his point of view
maybe even empathize with it a little
bit as we hate him and realize he's a
bad guy
um but we also have a personal
connection with this villain right this
whole backstory with Janet and that
seemed really rich to us I'm basically
out of time but just real fast uh you
you know that I'm I'm just curious how
much longer your director's cut was like
did you have a longer version of the
movie did you end up with a lot of
deleted scenes we always have a longer
version of the movie but I still even in
this sort of more epic Ant-Man thing
I was hell-bent you know the other
Ant-Man movies clock in right around two
hours I think this is just slightly
above two hours I like the idea of
telling the story in a concise way but
still being able to sort of stop down
and and again particularly in the middle
of the movie where you know you're
hearing Janet's backstory about Kang and
you're seeing Kang meet Scott for the
first time taking his time
um they're certainly there are longer
versions of scenes that are still in the
movie
um
there are a handful of things we
probably cut for time and they're always
painful decisions in the moment oh do we
cut this or whatever and then you can
cut something out it's like oh that just
lifts this whole section of the movie
I'm I'm endlessly fascinated by that
process on any movie but there'll
definitely be some some deleted stuff
that we'll be able to show yeah that
note I need to stop I really appreciate
the extra time because I know that was a
lot longer than eight minutes I'm just
gonna say thank you so much